you could order something top yeah man  of course  hello yeah can we have 15 pizzas 20  chicken wings seven chips and 24 onion  rings and four bottles of color okay  thank you  well since women my house are so let me  told us that the worst vessel to be  filled with the stomach so he gave us  advice it's a full of phony autonomy but  one-third of your stomach should be  filled with with food or full of finish  arabe here or one third of it should be  filled with fluids or drink was full of  from the deficit and one third of it  should be filled or should be occupied  with air in other words shouldn't be  filled with anything  well happy for the adviser keen Allah  bless you and when cancelled all you  know hope you guys enjoyed that video  don't forget to share subscribe and like  and join the down movement while  becoming at our movement member today by  clicking the link below